empathy understanding how others think
and feel is what connects us empathy
bonds us to our families friends and
colleagues and it influences how we
treat one another instinctively we know
this but we don't fully appreciate the
importance of empathy and designing
great products and improving employee
performance we also tend to miss just
how easily we can cultivate it po blob
is a nonprofit focused on harnessing
technology to improve health and
well-being their first product was a
video game for kids battling cancer hope
lab researchers started by listening to
the kids stories and they learned the
young patients fear cancer treatment
almost as much as cancer itself they
have to leave home for the hospital and
take chemotherapy a process that's often
painful in its own right yet sticking to
regular treatment is critical to their
survival
hope labs challenge emerged to shift the
kids attitudes so they viewed
chemotherapy not as another awful part
of having cancer but rather a weapon for
them to use hope lab designed the game
called remission so that you guide a
robot named Roxy through the body as she
blasts away cancer cells when Roxy runs
low on ammo you have her find a chemo
tap to power up so she can more
effectively fight the cancer and the
videogame worked in one study the kids
who played remission versus a control
game took their antibiotics more
consistently and doctors found higher
levels of chemotherapy in their blood
what's more the results of another study
showed that when players were actively
playing remission the mesolimbic region
of the brain the reward pathway
associated with motivation was activated
this activation was associated with a
shift in attitudes toward chemotherapy
that helped boost players adherence to
treatment through empathic insight
seeing the world from the point of view
of a young cancer fighter hope lab
created the game to help these kids more
effectively fight their disease
now let's look at employee performance
University fundraisers captured the
imagination of psychologists Adam grant
and his colleagues who were intrigued by
the motivational factors that drove the
fundraiser success when they called
alumni to ask for donations
now typically the fundraisers don't know
the scholarship recipients the direct
beneficiaries of the donations so in one
study the researchers asked some of the
fund raisers to spend five minutes
speaking with the scholarship student
enabling them to establish a personal
connection to the student before making
their calls the results the fundraisers
who established a personal connection
spent twice as long on the calls and
nearly tripled donations compared to a
control group fostering empathy makes
work personal the good news for business
leaders is that empathy is a skill that
can be learned psychologist Karina
Schumann and her colleagues ran one
study where they told half of their
participants that empathy is an innate
trait the other half were told it's a
skill that can be developed those in the
second group were more empathetic spent
more time listening to others and
demonstrated an increased willingness to
help others what's more new technology
is making it even easier to teach
empathy Jeremy bailenson and his
colleagues at Stanford use virtual
reality simulations to give people the
experience of walking around in someone
else's shoes the results of their
studies show that taking on the
perspective of another even for a few
minutes
creates more empathy we've known for a
long time that empathy strengthens our
bonds and impacts how we treat one
another but now an increasing amount of
evidence suggests that fostering empathy
can also help us design better products
and improve employee performance this
deep and powerful resource has largely
gone untapped in arenas where it can
serve us so well
perhaps most importantly this work shows
that empathy can be learned and that
integrating it into our professional
life is a choice we can all make